hi I'm Victoria Braun co-founder of big
Singh Kham the way we live and work is
changing at a faster pace than ever
before since Big Think launched in 2008
our mission has always been to help our
audience get smarter faster before at
you idea driven video interviews with
thousands of global thought leaders from
dr. Michio Kaku to Henry Rollins to
Salman Rushdie and many many more you've
helped us become one of YouTube's most
popular education channels with a really
vibrant community of users and now who
are responding to your feedback we've
created big think mentor to bring you
the world-class ideas of our experts
transferred into actionable tools to
help you lead more productive happier
and healthier lives up to 40% of skinny
people actually may be what we call
skinny fat people they look thin but
they're metabolically obese people will
work much harder not to lose something
than they will to gain something and
that's not depressing it's very useful
you can leverage that so basically what
research suggests is that focusing on
that focusing on the future focusing on
your goals makes people happy
you know striving actually makes people
much happier than actually then even
achieving I assert that if you were
depressed after learning and being
exposed to the cosmic perspective you
started your day with an unjustifiably
large
well update our programming each month
to respond to your changing needs
watch our expert video and then
reinforce your learning with a guided
thought experiment or life experiment
provided in the comment section below
report back on your results engage in
community debate and make
recommendations for new experts and
areas of study join us today and become
a founding member of big think mentor
you